we still have a new year's travel mess
across the country the biggest snowstorm
to hit the mid-atlantic in years left
even more travelers stranded after
dumping at least eight inches on
washington d.c virginia maryland and
delaware also saw record amounts of snow
the combination of snow and covid led to
more than 3 000 flight cancellations
yesterday errol barnett is in
springfield virginia errol good morning
hey there nate good morning i'm standing
off the i-95 here in virginia which is a
massively busy and important uh
thoroughfare through this part of the
country it was shut down in both
directions for 50 miles because of
accidents overnight behind me you're
seeing traffic be diverted off of the
highway and onto the surface streets
temperatures are below freezing the ice
beneath my feet is slippery and all of
those conditions will have an impact on
how travel nightmares play out today
you're looking at i-95 in stafford
county look at that images like this
played out all night as the biggest
snowstorm to hit the d.c maryland and
virginia region in three years upended
the commute of thousands this is the
view from our car literally the same
view that we've had for the past five
hours nisa semester was traveling from
massachusetts to north carolina and has
been stuck on i-95 in virginia she
recorded this at 3 a.m we are extremely
concerned for people who have limited
supply of food water and gas because if
they don't have gas they can't keep
their car running and they might
be freezing the state's department of
transportation says it's been working
one by one to clear tractor trailers
involved in crashes contributing to the
blockage but that's little comfort to
stuck commuters enduring bitter
temperatures that have dropped to 17
degrees i have never been this
frightened on the road before many have
been sharing their ordeals online
pleading for help including this from a
desperate parent with a four-month-old
in the back seat we haven't seen a plow
truck or a police officer
in seven hours airports also bearing the
brunt of the storm canceling even more
flights on top of the thousands already
scro it's a saga william humphrey and
his fiancee both pathologists are
stranded in nebraska after their flight
plans were canceled five times and
between that moment and the time that
the person helping us at the desk like
put my suitcase on the conveyor to check
it and then turns around and it says
that our flight's been canceled the
doctors are now considering driving the
more than 1300 mile journey home to
vermont so as to not risk more time away
from a hospital that's short staffed due
to covid it's kind of seeing what i've
been seeing at work now is affecting all
parts of our lives
now back here in virginia off the i-95 i
can tell you that we've seen emergency
vehicles move through here we know that
snow plows and tow trucks they are being
allowed through on the highway to help
those who are stranded and the big piece
of advice is that if it snowed heavily
wherever you are in the country it's a
very high likelihood that there was ice
overnight so if you don't have to hit
the roads today stay home uh
tony and stay safe
yeah good advice not a winter wonderland
where you are errol thank you very much